yeah welcome to a new video playing and
i am here this is tricky Egypt okay so
okay let's go to the Kings Indian so
often fun to play now 83 m as three is
the line that I played myself a couple
of times
okay I'm going for some counter play
here with the Queen a five yes we can do
that he's got 95 Nancy form maybe I was
a bit too quick with exchanging hmm ok
ok now it anyway and so it's always
tricky in this opening lost so many
games in the king's indian where was
completely winning as widened then some
silly tactica got me
hmm a three yeah Queen a 594 is really
not the move you want to see and maybe I
just prepare this I can play be five if
you take that this before hanging and
let's not think about this too much the
games i loosen the Kings Indian I always
lose to those players who play instantly
and then at the end I my mate it or
something this is strange I can take G
for you
and
okay ma'am then don't know I don't want
to want to exchange it really and maybe
I should have should have in this in
this case I'm just not looking at the
material here just trying to activate
all pieces to the to the maximum yeah
and let's go here he cannot cancel long
yeah this is not easy to play for white
with this position not saying that is
worse I'm just saying it's difficult to
play so rook rook be three
sure maybe it's got 92 though
96 but 96 is just a move that it's
leading nowhere ideas going to be eight
with the smooth oh I'm down on time and
oh he's opening the H file for me
I could also take with the f porn
although not bad the fr
hmm sure Joe I can just take it
yeah I didn't didn't see that at all
is there some some plain aiji-ma be this
purpose maybe threatens rugby too
I think I mean in blitz terms threatened
through [ __ ] be too
yeah well I cannot cannot retreat or
something so it's when if he needs to
play rook f3 which is really awkward
then this is probably not even so
incorrect
bishop wait wait was worth wait there is
something here Bishop g3 or so Bishop g3
takes Queen takes come online it need to
be quick i am rook takes Queen have to
mate I recruited to its got rocked it to
the Knights what probably Bishop e3 that
I should have played we should be three
ah crap now I don't have a move now
Jeff he was hanging her this is lucky
yeah somehow this game is still going on
yeah i forgot i got that the bishop is
attacking taking this haha what a silly
game them down to 15 seconds and i
cannot really if i look at this I'm sure
that I had something Bishop e3 or
overlooked this brooke d to move i mean
i'm really curious it's a bit bit silly
to continue actually yeah well he's got
he's got an open king so
what am i down rukan bishop okay yeah
okay just I could I can resign I qesm
Queen f7 okay and at five seconds on the
clock I'm sure that this wasn't wasn't
correct at all I mean it was just I was
just gambling here with with with the
Kings engineer but wait just wait I'm
curious so
yeah but should be three wins of course
it wins minus seven yeah it was clear
bishop g3 or III but I needed to play a
move and rook t2 and then this is just
over of course takes takes look everyone
and now okay i have i have got all kinds
of checks the best move was rupee eight
to be too and wins yeah I mean it's
clear that it's very dangerous hehe
doesn't have free look at it what a
coordination white has no coordination
at all and he can resign young yeah he
let me in and then in this this is rugby
two wins basically I can play rock every
now but and this was a rookie to yeah
yeah yeahs Queenie to is this even
halfway playable but ok it's it's lost
him Oh clearly worse yeah Bishop e3 yeah
I'm and I knew it hey I knew there was
something all right if thanks for
watching